embattled new york governor andrew cuomo
has broken his silence
on sexual misconduct allegations
he's still quiet about the thousands of
senior citizens that he killed and the
subsequent
cover-up and the federal investigation
into it but he wants you to know that he
is really
really sorry about maybe hugging
staffers
i certainly never ever
meant to offend anyone
or hurt anyone or cause
anyone any pain
that is the last thing i would ever want
to do
i never wanted to cause anyone pain
unless you're a senior citizen in which
case i want you dead
i want your family dead i want your
house burned to the ground
i want to go there in the middle of the
night i want to piss in the ashes
i'm andrew cuomo this is the michael
knowles show
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from heaton james
who asks has there ever been a time in
history
when the people banning books were the
good guys
the answer to this question actually is
yes
but you all ain't ready for that yet but
but it is actually
book banning book burning has gone on
for all of history it's going on
bad guys have done it good guys have
done it christians in the bible do it
uh the question is under what
circumstances how extensive
and what exactly is the kind of content
that is being
you could say banned or burned or
canceled this is the same sort of issue
that we've
been talking about for a couple of weeks
now it's not only the formal question
the procedural question of are you
canceling censoring showing consequences
for things you say
but what exactly are the things that you
were saying that are incurring
these consequences well hopefully we'll
get into that in the
ensuing weeks you know one way to feel
safe in this crazy world of ours
ring so much happens at our front doors
that is something that certainly has not
changed these days especially for me
i've got sweet little june my newborn
baby there
so i'm getting a lot of packages i'm
getting a lot of food delivery because
no one wants to cook right now
i'm getting a lot of in-laws coming by
and you know
if it's the pizza i'm maybe i'm going to
open the door if it's
other people maybe i'm not going to open
the door it's good to know who is
outside the door before you open the
door you can do that with ring
you can see and speak to whoever is
outside your house
whether you are in your bedroom maybe
you are at the office maybe you are on a
beach
somewhere on the other side of the world
i think this is an absolutely fabulous
housewarming gift one because it's
futuristic
two because it'll keep your friends safe
three it's not very expensive so you get
credit for a
nice gift and you don't need to shell
out a ton of money it makes me feel safe
knowing that when i travel sweet little
lisa can see who's outside the door
before she opens it right now
get a special offer on the ring welcome
kid at ring.com knowles it comes with
rings video doorbell 3 and chime pro the
perfect way
to upgrade your front door and store
your ring experience go to ring.com
knowles that is ring.com knowles cuomo
finally addressing these allegations
they have been bubbling up
for a couple of weeks now they actually
first came to light even longer ago
this idea that maybe cuomo was
inappropriate he said an inappropriate
thing to a woman right it's all kind of
very vague
stuff but now it's really coming to a
head
just conveniently just coincidentally as
we were focusing in on the covid scandal
the fact that cuomo's policies directly
led to the deaths
of thousands of elderly new yorkers and
he knew about it crucially he knew about
it
he covered it up and the feds were and i
suppose
are looking into it so cuomo he don't
want to talk about any of that stuff so
instead
he talks about his behavior and
while he says i'm sorry i didn't mean to
cause anybody pain he also provides some
excuses namely
that it's perfectly ordinary to kiss
everybody that you see on the street
uh you can go find hundreds of pictures
of me
uh kissing people uh men women
it is my usual and customary way
of greeting so this is obviously an
excuse i've met andrew cuomo
twice in my life and i can thankfully
say
he did not greet me in that way the
thing is there actually is some truth to
this
i say this as a new yorker i say this as
an italian-american
i come from a very similar culture i
think actually the same town as andrew
cuomo
we're a little bit more uh physical
we're a little bit more you know
we'll hug people it's obviously italians
in italy do like the kiss kiss cheek
cheek
but it's we're not as quite as
standoffish as some other cultures
so sure now does this mean
that uh andrew cuomo did not try to pick
up his staffers that he did not try to
do anything inappropriate
i don't know i'm not sure frankly
i don't care that andrew cuomo kissed
hundreds of people i care that his
policies killed
thousands of people and he covered it up
that's what i care about i've said this
from the beginning
that this is a distraction now do i
think this is a distraction
contrived by the cuomo team themselves
do i think that there was mastermind
cuomo sitting around saying okay
i'm really in hot water on the covet
thing let's distract let's have them
start talking about some
vague sex scandal no i don't think so i
mean it's possible the guy is an
absolute killer politician so it's
possible
but more likely what it is
is that the democrats pumped this guy up
they exalted this guy
and they they made him the greatest
coveted hero in the country absolutely
implausibly but if all you consume is
the mainstream media then then you would
believe that
and then turns out that his covid
policies
and by association their covid policies
were a complete failure and republican
covid policies
like namely florida governor ron
desantis
big success and so now that this guy
is really making them all look bad they
take him out with some contrived sex
scandal
that seems more likely to me but in any
case it is a distraction there's no
question about that
i knew it from the minute that this
scandal or pseudo scandal
bubbled up it also creates a problem for
democrats because democrats have been
saying for years now that we need to
support women and believe all women and
the minute that any
woman makes any accusation whatsoever
because of her
genetic equality that prevents her from
even being able to lie
ever we we have to believe her but what
happens when the ladies accuse
the democrat men they have to twist
themselves into pretzels
to explain their stance on it first
i fully support a woman's
right to come forward and i think
it should be encouraged in every
way wow that's really big of you andrew
cuomo you support
the right of women to
make accusations and try to get justice
wow oh my gosh
feminist of the year over here this guy
thinks that women are entitled to the
same rights as every american citizen
wow
incredible but he understands he might
he might not understand
how he's coming across right now but he
understands that he made some people
feel uncomfortable
i now understand that
i acted in a way that made
people feel uncomfortable
it was unintentional and i
truly and deeply apologize for it
i feel awful about it
and frankly i am embarrassed
by it and that's not easy to say
but that's the truth but this is what i
want you
to know and i want you to know this from
me directly
i never touched anyone
inappropriately i never
touched anyone inappropriately
i want you to say it after me i never
touched anyone inappropriately
luca brazzi get over here make sure that
they repeat after me
i never touched anyone
inappropriately okay the the waterworks
routine was not very persuasive
because andrew cuomo from the beginning
of his political career
has been a bulldog he has been a tough
tough dude ever since he was helping out
his father mario cuomo
another governor of new york with
presidential ambitions who ended up
not running cuomo now carrying on the
dynasty so it it's not very persuasive
when he says
i'm very embarrassed by it i'm very
humiliated he's trying to work up the
waterworks
it doesn't really work but then he gets
to his point he says this allegation is
bs
you know after this whole i think we
should listen to the women they should
come forward i'm this and that
this is bs is what he's saying and maybe
it is i don't maybe it is just a
contrived attack
that he's only suffering now because
of the kovit scandal i strongly suspect
it is because these
vague allegations have been kind of
floating in the ether for quite a while
democrats never cared about it
until now and then andy cuomo
used the classic democratic move
he made himself the victim i have
learned from what
has been an incredibly
difficult situation for me
as well as other people and i've learned
an important lesson i'm sorry
i'm sorry for whatever pain i caused
anyone
i never intended it
and i will be the better for this
experience
will you be the better andrew cuomo i
think you may be unemployed
because of this experience because this
isn't
uh republicans pushing this kind of
thing or republicans are
pushing the kovitz scandal which is the
actual scandal this is democrats who
have who have obviously lost faith in
you and what he's trying to show
with this presser is that he is still in
control here
he is not going to be pushed out by the
forces in his party that think that he
really
let them down that he's going to
continue on his path because the guy has
wanted to be president
since he was two years old there's a
biography of andy cuomo that came out
about six years ago it's called the
contender it's generally a
quite quite positive biography of him
but the point that it keeps coming back
to again and again is how tightly
controlled
andrew cuomo's press operation is his
images
and how obviously this is all about him
trying to run
for president now that's seeming a
little bit less likely speaking of press
conferences and presidents
you got to at least give andrew cuomo
credit for being able to go out there
and face the cameras and try to set his
own narrative
joe biden not doing that
joe biden now setting the record in
modern history for the uh longest time
a president has waited before giving his
first
press conference it's not only
conservatives attacking him for this
even
jake tapper who i think is
sometimes jake tapper i think tries to
portray himself as the only honest guy
in the room and he just talks about the
facts
jake tapper is a partisan democrat i
really
hate that whole shtick and routine that
he does he is as left as they come
in in the mainstream but he
he credit where credits do he does go
after biden here he says an analysis of
the past hundred years shows president
biden's 15
most recent predecessors all held a
formal solo press conference
within 33 days of taking office biden
has not
and it's day 42 and i i don't think
biden has any desire to do that
why because joe biden is not
particularly
uh persuasive when he was just giving a
a talk
a virtual sort of zoom talk with members
of congress
and he had no idea basically what he was
doing where he was they ended up having
to cut the feed from him
and i'm happy to take questions if
that's you i'm supposed to do nance
whatever you want me to do
and there it goes there it is no what we
want you to do joe is go away
sit go watch tv in your apartment
meanwhile the liberal establishment
is going to be pushing radical radical
policies that have not only transformed
the country over the last year
but seemed to be attempting to transform
the country in this
radical locked down way indefinitely
biden was asked not during a press
conference because he doesn't really do
that sort of thing he was asked though
well he was just kind of
walking he was in transit what
he thinks of the new normal you know
we're now we're now coming up on the one
year anniversary
of 15 days to slow the spread and we
joke about that but that is
really crazy and horrible for the
country
that these sociopaths have been able
to rest the power from us and our
political rights and traditions
and we've basically done nothing to stop
it and we've known
from some of us from the very beginning
but some of us from three weeks and four
weeks in
that they were not going to give up
power this wasn't gonna be two weeks or
two months now it's looking like it's
gonna be two
years joe biden asked when are we
getting back to normal he said ah
hopefully i don't know
maybe maybe in about a year
i caution not to give an answer to that
because we don't know for sure
but my hope is by this time next year
we're going to be back to normal
before that my hope but again it depends
upon if people continue
to continue to be
smart and understand that we still can
have significant losses
there's a lot we have to do yet so thank
you
two weeks to slow the spread has
actually now become
according to the president of the united
states
two years to slow the spread
when some of us mentioned that they
weren't going to give up power about a
year ago
we were told oh stop being a crazy
conspiracy theorist
oh stop being hyperbolic oh stop being a
catastrophist
when we were told that look if people
just wear the masks we'll get back to
normal that's that's the cost for
getting back to normal people wear the
masks
we have mask mandates all over this
country various places all over this
country with a few notable and admirable
exceptions
have the masks helped us get back to
normal
no as some of us pointed out a while ago
the masks were always going to prolong
this thing because the masks don't make
people feel safer
they make people feel more anxious you
look around you see all these people
wearing masks like a bunch of banditos
and you don't say okay
we're all good now you say oh my gosh
we're in an unprecedented event
oh my gosh we need to give the
government extraordinary powers we need
to give these psycho-politicians
more and more of our rights and our
liberties and that's just how it's going
to be
biden says i hope this time next year
i hope it's only only going to be two
years to slow the spread
but that's going to depend on if you're
a good little boy and you're a good
little girl
it's going to depend on if you do
everything i say if you don't
if you don't wear the mask and get the
shot
and social distance and cancel
thanksgiving and cancel christmas
do all the other nonsense i tell you to
do if you don't do it
maybe it's going to be three years to
slow the spread
ah gosh if you maybe it's going to be
four years maybe this is the new normal
like these people have been telling us
from the very beginning
and some of us who were listening we'll
remember that
but other people don't want to remember
it because it is so outrageous
meanwhile look at the various states
the states have been handling this
you've got a state like california
which has been locked down it's just
mussolini's
tyranny over there locked down more than
virtually any other state they're not
doing any better on covid
than florida which has been open
basically from the beginning
like quite open new york has been
extremely locked down
new york has done worse than any other
state on covid
that's why andy cuomo has to answer
questions about some ridiculous sex
scandal right now
not because of the sex scandals because
of covid
at least one reporter asks joe biden
this is again it's not a press
conference just sort of at the very end
they
try to shout a few questions to biden
they ask biden
hey mr president
florida's looking pretty good seems to
disprove all your stupid covid theories
what do you have to say about that joe
biden does not mince words
i hope everybody's realized by now these
masks make a difference
we are on the cusp of being able to
fundamentally
change the nature of this disease
because the way in which we're able to
get
vaccines in people's arms we've been
able to move that all the way up to the
end of may to have enough for every
american to get every adult american to
get a shot
and the last thing the last thing we
need is neanderthal thinking that
in the meantime everything's fine take
off your mask
forget it it still matters now
joe biden using this phrase neanderthal
thinking
actually carries quite a bit of weight
because joe biden remembers the
neanderthals you know when joe biden was
growing up in delaware
uh i forget during which uh era of the
earth's history
uh he knew a lot of neanderthals they
were wandering around
uh then you know very sadly they went
extinct and uh
now we live in this world without them
but he remembers what it was like and he
he doesn't want to go back to that
neanderthal thinking
so i just in my mind i've got to compare
two guys
ron desantis in florida kept the state
open
everybody's happy everybody's free virus
very well contained
andrew cuomo in new york
uh not doing great locked down the state
and killed a bunch of senior citizens
and took away his constituents liberties
and rights
if i'm and i'm just saying i don't even
want you to think ideologically here i
just want you to think as a purely
physical matter which of those guys
looks and sounds more like a neanderthal
is it ron desantis very articulate guy
you know he's
relatively handsome or is it andrew
cuomo
andrew cuomo with the looks just like a
bulldog i think it's probably
probably going to be the latter so
the really the only reason the cuomo's
cuomo sex scandal matters is because it
reveals something about the way that the
coronavirus has played out i think now
a year into slowing the spread a year
before
joe biden says maybe he hopes we're
going to stop having to slow the spread
it's pretty clear the republican
policies worked and by the way
a lot of republicans went squishy on
this so i'm excluding them from my
analysis
but the people who wanted to stay open
lose those stupid masks
let kids go to school go let everybody
go to church
the people who wanted to do that were
100 right
and people like dr fauci and all the
other technocrat tyrants and lab coats
and all of the other sociopath
democratic politicians
were completely 100 percent wrong dr
fauci was asked about this it's hard to
say that dr fauci was wrong because he's
held every side of every single position
depending on the political convenience
to him but he actually
got to give a little bit of credit to
cnn i can't believe how much of that i'm
doing in recent days
dr fauci was asked hey uh
florida you know the same question that
biden was asked
florida look we want to defend news and
we want to defend cuomo we want to
defend you
oh exalted dr fauci but florida
and some of the other republican states
it's it's like it's fine so does that
mean
that the republicans got something right
some states that shut down obviously and
and had all those mandates new york
michigan massachusetts all have higher
death rates
do you think it's possible when you look
up back on this that it may be that
desantis did some things right
well i'm sure he did i i mean i don't
think it would be fair to say that that
the governor of florida did everything
wrong not at all
there were certain things that would
that were done that
that i disagreed with and that it wasn't
just me personally it's the public any
public health person
who looked at it but i think it would be
unfair to say that he did everything
wrong
this guy is such a twerp i can't get
over it
he's asked hey fauci or not vagi
rhonda santa hey mr vouche ron desantis
did way better than andy cuomo and
governor newsom and all these other
people
so cuomo and newsome follow your advice
and ron desantis told you to go pound
sand and he's doing better than all
those other guys
so maybe did he get something right well
i think
maybe he did certain things right in his
life
he studied for his exams he brushed his
teeth in the morning
and so i'm not it's not fair to say that
he
did every single thing in his entire
life wrong
but i disagree with his approach to the
virus so he won't
he won't grant it it's a it's a direct
question and he just
evades it because if you contradict the
exalted doctor faji you must be wrong
even if the revolt results say otherwise
what exactly
did he get right fauci goes on are there
are there some things when you look at
florida that you that you think that he
did get
right well you know
we uh erin we had uh often
um talks uh on a weekly basis
during the last administration with the
mayors of miami and
of dade county and you know some of the
things that were done
down there by the by people at the local
level really actually
did work i mean they were very careful
they tried really very hard
this guy is just unbelievable
shameless what did ron desantis who did
a great job what did he get right
he had democrat mayors that's what he's
saying what did ron desantis
get right his democrat mayors talk to me
i'm right i'm right please please
believe
me except except he's not and the longer
this madness goes on the clearer it is
but they
are still not going to let up
ben is going to be talking about this
very fact today on his show why the left
is so
enraged about reopening so make sure to
stick around check that out also
you know there's a ton of crazy
left-wing theories out there in some
cases some outright lies
and they need to be called out for what
they are they need to be
in a word debunked well ben does exactly
that on the daily wires newest series
debunked in the first episode which was
released on friday
ben debunks a lot of myths surrounding
the minimum wage
you've heard the arguments hiking up the
federal minimum wage
is the only livable humane way forward
well what the liberal activists and the
politicians
don't acknowledge is that the minimum
wage was not intended
to be livable and that very often it
hurts
more people than it can help then we'll
go into the details here debunked is now
available to daily wire members
exclusively are you not a member yet
we'll go to dailywire.com
subscribe use code debunked to get 25
off your new membership
and stay tuned for this friday's episode
where ben will break down the unions i
hope he just breaks the unions but he'll
at the very least
break down the unions head on over to
dailywire.com we'll be right back with a
lot more
dr fauci was wrong
a lot of people from the mainstream on
the right and the left
are acknowledging this now mostly
people from the mainstream right but a
handful of people
from the mainstream left but it goes
beyond the mainstream
even people on the fringes of the right
and on the fringes of the left
are finally going after dr fauci and
this public health
dictatorship including one of the more
odious people
who is in public life who has made a
career
out of saying revolting things
louis farrakhan the head of the nation
of islam
a radical a racialist he took a break
from his usual sort of race hustling
to go after dr fatchi
fauci well he may be a good man for some
things and
for some people dr alim didn't want to
say anything negative about him i
understand
don't choose him over me that's right
that's right that's right
it's the nano particles
that men like dr
fauci have
proprietary knowledge of
that allows them to get a patent
that's right for their vial of death
we don't need none of that
you know i saw this clip talking about
the
the vaccine as a vial of death and how
fouchy is this awful evil guy
from louis farrakhan and i thought you
know even a stop clock twice a day no
i'm kidding i'm kidding for all the fact
checkers i'm
kidding don't you dare i
when somebody sent me this clip i said
don't make me agree with louis farrakhan
but i'm not i'm only
i'm only joking uh i'm joking much less
about dr fauci of course dr fauci is
just
awful he is an absolute box on our
public life
he should be removed from his position
where he has
been for 40 50 years uh
goodness gracious if the entire
mainstream right some of the mainstream
left the far right and even the kind of
radical far
left the guys like louis farrakhan
everybody
seems to have woken up to this for one
reason or another
for legitimate reasons or for perhaps
illegitimate reasons
as we've seen uh but we we're all
getting something namely
this guy fauci is just no good
for our public life now i hate
i hate that in any way i have to even
agree with like
half of a percent of a thing that louis
farrakhan has intimated while still
disagreeing with 99 of the things he
says in that very same breath
uh such is the case in our public life
right now speaking of militant radicals
like louis farrakhan
maybe you've heard if you watch the
mainstream media certainly you have
heard
we're we're getting ready for
an insurrection another
from the right the trumpest forces
bloomberg reporting quote a militant
group
may be plotting to attack the u.s
capitol on thursday
a day tied to conspiracy theories about
march 4th
police warn march 4. i've seen this
in other mainstream media publications
they say march 4th
that's the day there's going to be a
coup there's going to be an insurrection
i asked last time i was in dc i said why
is the national guard still in dc
a month after the riot at the capitol
why why why does dc
still look like some occupied
city we were told that they were here to
prevent
a coup d'etat why does it look like a
coup d'etat here with all the all these
guardsmen
and i was told the answer i heard was
march 4th there they've heard that
there's going to be an insurrection on
march 4th i said i
you know i spend an inordinate amount
of my day delving the depths of
right-wing commentary
online and
i haven't seen anything about an
insurrection on march 4th
have you do you if you're listening
right now probably you pay attention to
some conservative commentary have you
seen anything about that no
seems to me that the only people hyping
this alleged insurrection on march 4th
are left-wing journalists isn't that
weird
isn't that a strange circumstance you
would think that if this were a
right-wing insurrection
that the left would be downplaying it or
but instead they seem to be promoting it
they seem to be hyping it
maybe they want something to happen
maybe they want an
excuse to continue
to erode our liberties and our
traditions and our rights in this
country
just as they have been doing for at
least a year now
maybe they want an excuse to ramp it up
ramp up the censorship
ramp up the lockdowns ramp up the
security all around
dc seems pretty weird to me
speaking of insurrectionist
subversive forces you may have heard
that at cpac last week the conservative
political action conference
the stage at cpac was
built in the shape of a nazi symbol
you say what hold on i actually i wasn't
able to make it to cpac this year
i did they made a swastika shaped stage
that seems like a big oversight
man we got to call match lap that seemed
you know clearly they they uh
missed something here then i looked at
the stage and i said oh that's no that's
not a swastika
that's just if anything it looks kind of
like that that random symbol that prince
changed his name into
remember when he lost his name and he
became the artist formerly known as
prince and it looks kind of like that
but it doesn't when i look at that i
don't see a nazi symbol the left
they saw nazi symbols this was being
reported everywhere so it turns out
turns out that the allegedly
nazi stage was designed by a company
called design foundry
that uh has not just worked for well it
has not worked for the nazis
and they've not just worked for the
right wing they've worked for
joe biden and they've worked for msnbc
and 98 of the company's political
donations
have gone to democratic candidates
pretty strange stuff the
left refers to these
sorts of symbols and sort of statements
that if you looked at that stage you
said it's completely innocuous
if you heard many things that
right-wingers say you say completely
anodyne stuff and they refer to this as
dog whistles so for instance if i if i
come out and i say you know
they got rid of a lot of intel election
integrity protections
in 2020 and we need to protect our
elections
the left will say that's a dog whistle
for
you don't want black people to vote if
if i come out and i say you know i love
my country and i want law and order in
this country they'll say that's a dog
whistle for racism
and fascism and nazism and you say it's
all these dog whistles and i say
i don't see that i don't hear any of
that
and we are reminded that if you're
hearing
dog whistles all the time
it means you're the dog right you are
and i think that's what the democrats
are saying about themselves here
they are attuned to these things because
it has a resonance for them they
they are obsessed with race so they see
racism everywhere
they're obsessed with nazism or fascism
so they see nazis and fascists
everywhere lots and lots of dog whistles
and they are determined
to root that out we know that this
country the defining feature of it is
pervasive racism
that's what the left tells us and we
need to root that out from the very very
beginning which is why now
in new jersey five-year-olds in
kindergarten are receiving
training in diversity equity in
inclusion they are receiving
so-called anti-racism training
the democratic governor of new jersey
phil murphy signed this
bill into law forcing teachers
to instruct students as young as five
in diversity and inclusion and equity
intolerance
and belonging in connection with gender
and sexual orientation
race and ethnicity disabilities and
religious tolerance
now forget you know whenever you hear
this term diversity inclusion and equity
or any
permutation of that what that means is
leftist orthodoxy that's what they're
going to be trained in from a young age
and i've seen some people protest this
and they've said
you know babies aren't racist is another
one or you know little children
aren't bigoted and we don't we don't
need to teach them this if you want to
have this kind of program of education
wait until later i think those
conservative critics are totally missing
the point
this makes perfect sense if you want to
get your country to be more left-wing
it's not going to be nearly as useful to
teach 18 year olds as it will be to
teach eight-year-olds as it will be to
teach five-year-olds
the younger kids are the more malleable
their minds are the less they know the
easier it is to shape
the way that they view themselves the
way they view the world the way they
view the country
and so absolutely if i were a left
winger i'd want to get into the
kindergartens frankly i think
we should get into the kindergartens as
conservatives and teach
students not this radical gender theory
or whatever
we should get into the kindergartens and
teach them what they were once taught in
kindergarten namely
george washington was a good guy our
country is a good country a country that
you ought to have
loyalty and respect for that god exists
that uh we believe certain things we
don't believe
other things we ought to teach them
those
children will be taught values it is not
possible to have education without
values
i know there's this kind of liberal
dream among
left-wing liberals but even some
right-wing liberals you know people who
say
i just i want to get the indoctrination
out of the classroom i just want them to
learn
their arithmetic and you know the three
r's or no
it doesn't work that way education is
about the whole person it's about
developing virtues suppressing vices
uh understanding how to view the world
and the left is very successful at this
and the right is very unsuccessful at
this
because this is actually the topic of my
book my upcoming book that amazon is
almost certainly going to cancel
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
we conservatives like to believe that we
understand
education so much better than the left
does we understand free speech so much
better than the left us
i don't think we do i think that the
left and i think the intellectual
leftists
who developed this system that we now
call woke-ism
or political correctness or or whatever
word you want to use for it i think they
understood those things
much better than conservatives do and
it's why they were able to transform it
and only by understanding what they
really think
or we're going to be able to change
course because our current strategy on
this
is failing speaking of young people
speaking of failing strategies
a large number of migrants are headed
to the united states right now this is
often the case
but they're headed there in higher
numbers than usual
they're approaching california and
they're wearing joe biden t-shirts
not joking there's a photograph of a
group of
migrants heading toward america wearing
t-shirts that say biden
please let us in biden please let us in
raises a few questions one
if these migrants are able to get these
nice brand spank and new t-shirts they
see you know really good
one it means this is not just some
randomly you know grassroots springing
effort
of people who are destitute just seeking
survival even you know as we're always
told refugees who are going to be killed
in their home countries and that's why
we need to let them into the united
states
no this is pretty well organized they
have access to
a decent number of resources somebody
is obviously organizing them
someone with a political agenda and
there
i don't something tells me they're not
here fleeing the marauders or the
political persecutors in their home
countries right they seem
they're they're just kind of calmly
walking through mexico walking up to the
united states
they're obviously economic migrants who
are seeking
they actually are seeking a better life
for for their children and their
families there's no question about that
i'd rather live in america than i i
would in mexico or guatemala or
something like that
but the situation is not what the
democrats are telling us democrats are
telling us this is about just life and
death and no it's not it's about people
making more money and having more
opportunity for their kids okay i
understand that
so that's why we have a nice immigration
policy in part because we
are very compassionate but if you fling
the doors open
you no longer have a country anymore we
already have
the most open immigration policy in the
world
if you look at the number of migrants
who've entered the united states in the
last 60 years or so it's the largest
movement of peoples ever in the history
of the world
so as compassion as we want to be you
might have to
you might have to dial that back a
little bit because
if all your focus is on people from
other countries foreign nationals coming
into yours
then you are disadvantaging people in
your own country and the
responsibility of a government
is to protect its own citizens and this
government is failing to do that
why are the migrant caravans coming now
is it because of some political event
that happened in their own countries no
it's because joe biden has lenient
immigration policies
so when you have tough immigration
policies you disincentivize immigration
during the first few months of of the
trump administration illegal
crossings plummeted they started to tick
back up after that when they saw that
actually the policies didn't really have
much teeth
trump talked to good game but he was
largely prevented from implementing his
tougher policies
joe biden is saying yeah the doors are
wide open come on in
and the migrants and more importantly
the people organizing the migrants know
that joe biden is going to be pushing
for a mass amnesty and the democrats
know that that mass amnesty is likely to
give them
many many many many new voters
so that migrant care is just going to
keep on coming and it's bad for the
migrants there's a lot of crime that
happens
there's a lot of injury that happens
while people are crossing that border
illegally
it's bad for them it's certainly bad for
the country but the democrats don't care
because they see a political advantage
in it
so as we have this horde of migrants
coming up to the california border you
have the governor of california in
really hot water he just went too far
governor pretty boy governor patrick
bateman is not looking good
it looks as though he is going to be
recalled
i mentioned this story a couple of
months ago
when the recall effort for newsome had
hundreds of thousands of signatures
and i said it's looking like he'll be
recalled but it's not certain
because to recall newsome and then have
a new election
you need to have 1.5 million signatures
and at the time this was now a few weeks
ago yeah
it was 1.2 million or something so
people said oh he's definitely going to
get it but it's not just enough to have
1.2 or 1.5 million
because what democrats are going to do
is invalidate a large number of those
signatures if someone
has moved out of state if someone's not
living at the address that they say they
are they're going to get rid of those
signatures
this is what republicans should have
done to the illegal voters in
2020. people who put down addresses
where they didn't live stephen crowder
just did a good video
exposing how certain voters in 2020
if you go up to the houses that they say
they lived at the buildings don't even
exist there
so we should have done a better job of
kicking ineligible voters off the rolls
and fraudulent voters off the rules
democrats are going to do that but i
think now
they're not going to be able to overcome
it because it's not just 1.5 million
trying to recall newsome
now we're up to 1.9 million there's
still two weeks left
this thing is going to blow past 2
million so
who's going to step into the breach
there is
rumor that rick grinnell is going to
run for governor i don't know i haven't
spoken to
former ambassador grinnell about this
sort of thing
but he is kind of making the rounds it
looks as though he could he would be a
strong candidate he would be a strong
republican candidate in california is he
the most right-wing guy
in the republican party no he isn't
absolutely not
trump likes him a lot and he
seems to have done a good job when he
was acting director of national
intelligence
he's got some more socially liberal
positions
more socially liberal than my positions
that's for sure but we are talking about
california we're dealing with political
realities here
william f buckley jr had what was called
the buckley rule he said
that that conservatives should vote for
the most
they should vote for the most right
viable
candidate so this involves a lot of
prudence and political calculation
if we could get uh i don't know who
would be who would be right-wing enough
for me in california
attila the hunt let's say attila the
hunt decided that he was going to
challenge
gavin newsom and you know you had hun
hun
2020 or 2021. uh okay that would be one
thing but attila the hun
is not going to win in california a a
far-right candidate's not going to win
grinnell seems to be positioned in a in
a pretty decent way
to do it and anybody as far as i'm
concerned would be better than gavin
newsom newsom is really awful he's both
vacuous and willing to go over to the
far radicals here so we'll we'll see
what happens
we did get a republican governor once
through a recall effort when california
recalled gray davis
we ended up getting arnold
schwarzenegger also kind of a liberal
republican i guess he was better than
some of the alternatives but he was a
little more
a little more centrist uh we'll have to
see luck does play a role in a lot of
these sorts of things
there's a new book out called lucky how
joe biden barely won the presidency
this book is by jonathan allen who's a
senior analyst for nbc news and amy
porns
who's a senior correspondent with the
hill and
this book savages the joe biden campaign
not the biden administration but the
biden campaign
it's got all these little juicy tidbits
you know these all kind of political
gossip books have
one is that barack obama famously
refused to support joe biden
for most of the campaign because he
feared that biden was quote
a tragicomic caricature of an aging
politician
having his last hurrah
hard to see the lie there that's true
did obama say that i don't know
we'll get to those kind of questions in
a second uh one biden aide apparently
told the authors of this book that the
strategy
uh that they were pursuing was
tantamount to quote
you put your dumb uncle in the basement
so they just hid
joe biden in the basement of his house
he barely campaigned
and the excuse was because of kovid it
was it would be irresponsible to
campaign
and so joe biden's not going to do that
and then
what they avoid is the biggest liability
of the campaign which is joe biden
one trump adviser apparently told the
authors that the biden team quote
used coronavirus as an excuse to keep
him in the basement and it was smart
biden was able to hide his biggest
weakness which is himself
and he did it with an excuse that
sounded responsible
do i believe the claims made in this
book or not
i i want to avoid the charge of
hypocrisy here
and i i think i think that sometimes
what happens is when there are books
that are out that are
flattering to your side you believe them
and then when books are critical of your
side you
don't believe them and this seems
hypocritical
in this case i've mentioned this before
but not in a while
in this case it is not hypocritical
it is not hypocritical to give more
credence
to mainstream books written by
mainstream journalists
that are critical of democrats when you
wouldn't do the same thing for
republicans
because the people who wrote the book
are on the same team as joe biden
nbc news the hill the mainstream
media are on the same team as
the democratic politicians so when the
media
leak juicy information about the
democrats it carries more credibility
than when the mainstream media leak
juicy information about republicans
because we know that the mainstream
media lie about republicans all the time
first of all they're adversaries
so there's an incentive for them to post
the worst stuff and just make stuff up
whole cloth
but also they just don't have decent
access in the way that
because the media and the left are exact
and the democrats rather are exactly the
same thing
they have great access very often they
are literally sleeping with one another
so do i believe this book i give it way
more credibility i don't i don't really
pay a lot of attention
to any of these sort of gossipy books
but i i do i do give it a lot more
credibility
than i would to some republican book
you're gonna have to be watching the
same thing play out here with
andrew cuomo andy cuomo
is under attack right now by the media
so you're going to have to ask questions
why are they attacking this why are they
liking this and what does it matter to
me i don't give a damn about the juicy
gossip
from a political book like lucky and i
frankly don't give a damn about the
juicy gossip about how
andy cuomo watched a reporter read a hot
dog one time at the state fair i don't
care
i want to know how does this affect our
politics
and why are these stories being leaked
now what is the political strategy
because when it comes to these sorts of
scandals
nothing is what it seems all of this
very often is a distraction to la las
into accepting more of the left's agenda
the new normal now past two weeks now up
to two years now probably
going to be even longer i'm michael
moses the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadovsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire
2021 today on the ben shapiro show texas
and mississippi open back up
and the democrats and media lose their
ever loving minds that's today on the
ben shapiro show give it a listen